Jesus Christ
yeah no good to go okay what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings
and today we open up season six with
Johnny Knoxville you know them as the
star and co-creator of Jackass hit films
like bad grandpa and the ringer and
speaking of you can catch him in his
latest movie action point now in
theaters
Johnny welcome to the show you talked so
much faster when the cameras are rolling
than when you do when the cameras aren't
rolling yeah and I just I just had to
adjust and now I'm adjusted I'm doing
wonderful thank you for having me I
think you've sped up a little bit too
yes yes yes
as someone who suffered countless
concussions and broken their Jim dog all
in the name of entertainment my guess is
that today's challenge will be a walk in
the park but I do have to ask how are
you a spicy food I'm okay I'm okay
you'll start getting funny for me around
here I think so we'll see how it goes
all right well new season new sauces I'm
doing this gauntlet for the very first
time right along with you Johnny all
right you ready get it going yes
[Music]
all right so this first one is the
howler monkey the howler monkey mm-hmm
okay I have to eat on the side sorry
[Music]
your hasn't got funny yet very good dog
so I'm gonna start by rolling back the
clock because as I understand it you
inherited your love for juvenile pranks
from watching your father staged
gunfights at Christmas or serve his
buddies laxatives milkshakes what was it
like growing up with a joker for a dad
did he have an all time prank
I used constantly doing things he has
such charisma and he was so loud and and
yeah and I think he maybe should have
been in show business
my dad had all these crazy guys working
in his tire company ass-kickin robber
big George big Sam ww Woodrow Wilson
boxcar Johnson jr. so I grew up with a
lot of big characters in my life and my
kids have the same type crazy uncles
around so I've kind of recreated my
childhood a little with my kids
what's the johnny knoxville prank or
stunt that you hope your kids never find
on the Internet
my oldest didn't see jackass until she
was 14 but even then I made her sit next
to me in the theater and sometimes I
made her cover her eyes ears or both it
can be alive if you're young didn't see
that especially with your father doing
it
it's this next was the heartbeat hot
sauce okay a little hotter a little
hotter it's how it's designed so I
switch gears and talk about action point
because I know that the movie it's
inspired by this real-life theme park in
New Jersey that featured 50
mile-per-hour go-karts and the infamous
cannonball loop waterslide what can you
tell the people about the original
action park how was a place that was
just stacking up hundreds of injuries
per summer able to stay in business well
it was a different time it was the late
70s early 80s and you know the lawyers
hadn't come in and made everything safe
for everybody even for the 70s it was a
control they had this genius owner gene
Mulvihill like I'm not gonna hassle the
kids with a bunch of rules I'm gonna
leave safety up to them and he did and
it was insane it was Lord of the Flies
with booze and weed and it's like the
kids would design the rides and the kids
work the rides and they were usually
high or drunk there was there were no
adults around and it was a magical place
one that can't exist anymore all right
you ready to move on Johnny yes we have
this little garbage can if you want to
ditch if you want to keep it around
that's up to you
what's more aesthetically pleasing I
would say tossing it but you know okay
well the Pirates Lantern they really
shot the moon on that title there's one
just kind of mustardy maybe that should
have been first so I probably speak for
a lot of our viewers and I say that I
grew up watching you to take nut shots
so if you'll humor us I want to hit you
with some questions that I've always
been dying to ask you about jackass is
it true that you had to talk Brad Pitt
off the ledge when he wanted to do a
prank that was just bigger than the one
that you guys had planned for him well
yeah I mean he showed up ready we had
him in two bits one we kidnapped him in
front of Pink's hot dogs which went
really well and the first time we had
him for one night we were doing these
go-karts bombing the hill on vine and we
were all really like oh we don't want
him to
hurt because he's Brad Pitt is so but he
was he did not care he was ready to do
it and he was the first one in the
middle of the street we're like no no no
don't do that but he eating here when
you think back on all the pranks the
stunts that the cameras didn't catch the
onset things that the cameras didn't
catch is there a story that stands out
well that happens all the time it is
frustrating though especially if you
just got smoked
yeah no no you can't because someone
clicked off this camera this person was
shooting at the sky and it's just part
of who's the person the Jackass cast her
crew that you think deserves more credit
I don't know if any of us deserve any
credit
we give Aaron Magee he'd a lot of [ __ ]
but he Heat what he gets great footage
yeah there I said it
what's the key to finessing or release
out of an unsuspecting member of the
public because but some people might not
realize is you not only have to execute
this stunt this prank then you also have
to get your mark to agree to appear on
camera that's a very very tough thing to
do sometimes you have to wait a day
sometimes you can get them to sign later
and sometimes they just won't sign and
that's frustrating too that's just like
missing a shot right because then you're
like I can't use this yeah we yeah so
that that doesn't happen that much
anymore but it does happen and that's
very frustrating so this next one is the
torchbearer son of zombie that's a
mouthful I feel it more on the tips of
my lips if you know what I'm saying I
don't feel it in my mouth I feel like
it's tingling on the outside of my lips
so I saw an Instagram post were in 1995
you wrote a story for bikini magazine
called how to survive in Vegas on no
money a day do you remember any tips
from that story yeah never write for
Ryan a union because every article he
would give me is like hey you're gonna
go to Vegas on no money a day how about
hitchhiked to Dallas or no money a day
cheap bastard just didn't want to give
me any
you've gotta depend on the kindness of
strangers but I don't remember it's been
a long time there's been a lot of
concussions since right right you can't
expect me to remember from 95 digging
deep because you know that's what you're
doing you're pitching these articles and
I do wonder when you think back on some
of these lesser-known gems are there any
that stand out well the one that kind of
started my involvement in stunts is the
one wide tested self-defense equipment
on myself for Big Brother Jeff Tremaine
was the editor of Big Brother and he was
the director of Jackass and most of the
guys came from Big Brother you know and
as somebody who took red pepper spray to
the face and shot themselves if you
needed a self-defense tactical device if
you're in a fight for your life which
one would you reach for pepper spray
have no questions because stun gun you
have to get close to someone within
reaching distance that's dangerous and a
taser gun the first time I got shot I
had didn't have a shirt even have a
shirt on and one bounced off and then
they both have to be in you for the
circuit to connect pepper spray you can
be 15 feet away and just blast someone
in the face it just does not go away and
they're like all use milk that'll help
me be milked as an owl people say the
same thing to me about the wings yeah
does it help I'm kind of like no but
thanks for the tip it's like bulls they
hate the color red Bulls don't care
about the color red they just hate
movement they just hate you
[Music]
oh is this your guys own brand mm-hmm oh
but if you think it's trash told me it's
the trash daddy
mine mine mine OHS has been broke a few
times so my taste buds don't work that
well so like my own position but this
stuff let me tell you most calientes
delicioso all right Johnny will River
current segment on our show called
explain that grande where you do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram poll
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture then you just tell
me the bigger story does that sound good
I'd love that Thank You Phil there's
some damn tough wings yes what happened
here that I got hit with the water hose
with the air cannons attached to it and
it knocked me back
and the only thing stuff the moment my
momentum was my face hitting the slide
and I got stitches of my right eye I got
gnarly whiplash for like six weeks in
the concussion from that one
it was the most injuries I've ever had
on the film and I asked the stunt men
and women to do the stunts like me as
well like no pads no wires like every
other film you're going to see this
summer this is we're doing them for real
now Carolina Reapers at the hottest
pepper in the world it is the hottest
pepper in the world very impressive you
ever put one in the boot no I think I'd
be a bad idea I think I think I just
wrote a really great bit for this show
for you yeah yeah
there's no going back you know as
somebody who's just eaten it twice the
conventional way I'm playing that out in
my head and then combined with like the
taste of this wing and I'm having PTSD
mmm it's better if you have that on
camera that's true got it afterwards you
know spicy yeah very spicy so last
August we had steve-o on the show and he
actually picked up a call from you and
answered it on speaker do you
remember that remember yeah yeah don't
answer your phone in the middle of doing
a show okay he was very excited to get a
call from you
I love Stevo he made it through as well
right he did no problem and when he
explained the concept of this show to
you you said I'm getting harder than
Portland cement just thinking about it
how does the reality compare now that
you're here oh man I'm yeah harder than
a turnbuckle now and then just even
listening to you guys talk for that
brief moment it's clear that you have a
very special relationship what was your
impression of Stevo and he first met him
well when we first met him he drove
everyone up the wall you know because
he's a lot he can be a lot I think the
first time Dimitri and Tremaine from Big
Brother Magazine shot was steve-o they
were shooting with him and they were
going somewhere house and on the way to
the next location they're like oh god
[ __ ] this guy let's lose him like they
were trying to get away from him but
they couldn't shake him he's unshakable
and he just grows on you he knows he can
be a lot and he's uh he's something else
bun stirs black label mm-hmm thought was
instantly hot mm-hmm it's getting real
mm-hmm
can I get some more water the water in
the can
thank you can you draw back the curtain
on what it's like to master - stunts
like is it something that starts off as
a sketch and then it goes through some
sort of writers room process is it more
complicated than that is it less
complicated than that
I don't know if there's any master Minds
working on those stunts but sometimes we
get together and write like in the case
of the prank on Aaron McGee at the end
of jackass number two that one just
everyone just kept piling on and it kept
getting more ridiculous and more
ridiculous and he's not gonna fall for
this but if he does then maybe they'll
fall for it just kept snowballing that
one is one of our favorites and then in
YouTube there's a little bit of a
controversy around this prank culture
because you'll have people getting
millions of views faking terrorist
attacks or race-baiting in certain
neighborhoods and I'm wondering do you
have any prank rules are there lines
that you won't cross we try to aim
everything at ourselves the stuff you're
talking about it gets dark and it's not
funny when you bring all that anger into
it there's a way to do a prank and get a
big reaction and not have to go to those
places God my lips are really hot yeah
[Music]
the bomb
instantly hoppy I felt like I could
choke for a second hmm very interesting
[Music]
Jesus Christ yeah no dude ago so in
addition to the countless surgeries and
broken bones it seems like one of the
pitfalls and being johnny Knoxville is
having this public persona as this
indestructible man do people still crack
you over the head with beer bottles or
is that sort of chilled out over time oh
[Music]
wow
glasses fogging up a little bit yeah
that was hot well when the show and film
first came out people would try to
challenge me to fights and mm-hmm-hmm I
can't fight if you want to prove you're
tough why don't you go you know jump on
that guy over there with the the
cauliflower ears
you're not gonna prove you're tough by
beating me up that's happened a lot how
you feeling I'm feeling wonderful lips
are a little hot are you gonna do that
Carolina Reaper
thank you I'm bringing that to the
finale yeah keeping the eyeballs you
know okay all right
poof all right we're ready I'm ready all
right
[Music]
yeah this one doesn't feel great
[Music]
hmm
still harder than a turnbuckle yeah yeah
I think it's probably like pushing a
chain right now so I understand that
you're somewhat of a theme song
aficionado and used to cruise around
with a mixtape full of songs from the
Godfather and Breakfast tiffany's if you
were stuck on a desert island what would
be three movie soundtracks that you need
to help hold you over Wow
movie soundtracks well of course
Breakfast at Tiffany's I love The
Godfather but I don't know what sitting
around listening to the Godfather
soundtrack is going to put me in a
special place
the last song in cinema paradiso is
really pretty I think I was on there
with The Breakfast at Tiffany's not the
most butch stuff is there a story behind
how Corona by the Minutemen became the
theme song for jackass and we was just
indistinct to a bunch of songs and I I
submitted that and bastards of young by
the replacements and everyone liked
Corona by the Minutemen all right Johnny
Knoxville and now this is one of your
guys hot sauces it is one of our hot
sauces so this is a new one it's the
last dab redux which not only has pepper
acts from our original recipe but also
ate chocolate pepper ice Oh crazy add
pucker button alright alright so this is
the last dab products and because it's
the season 6 premiere I'm going hard in
the paint so it's not just one little
extra dab what I'm doing is the first
ever quadruple dab
from four different bottles yeah because
there's four different kinds you don't
have to go over along for the ride if
you don't want to
I gotta be care that was a little bigger
dab than I anticipated it's a dangerous
game then the Carolina Reaper
oh yeah you got to mix it all up mix it
all up
you've done this before
oh man should've went to college
is eye contact weird I'm into a
five-figure there I go I got it now
there's no fun no all right Johnny here
we are at the top of spice Mountain as
we've talked about today there's a lot
about the influence of Johnny Knoxville
from the star spawn from jackass to the
outlandish sense of humor but I think
was most subversive about the whole
thing was this embracing of failure it's
a walking counterpoint to America's
obsession with winning so I have to ask
you what's your advice to the people out
there who think that they have to be
perfect in order to succeed that if
they're not the best of the best that
there's no point in going on well if if
you're not failing at something you're
not trying hard enough
failing is part of it you know if you're
not trying hard enough to even fail then
I think you're in trouble because that
you know teaches you more sorry I just
noticed my beer was empty and there it
is wise words from Johnny Knoxville the
season 6 premiere 10 chicken wings up 10
chicken wings down so impressive from
this side of the table now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life whoo
well action Point comes out June 1st and
me and my cousin have a radio show on an
outlaw country channel 60 called the
big-ass happy family Jubilee God my lips
are burning
[Music]